the joggin experience naturally created
vision but that an improved vision and
it was one of several things they think
led to a evolving quicker one of them
was that we started experimenting with
different food sources but more access
to like bugs and you know rats and all
those little things that we could catch
we started hunting things then we
started using tools to figure out how to
hunt things and all during this process
we're eating weed and we're eating
mushrooms so we're probably interacting
with the psychedelic compounds that
people have used for thousands and
thousands of years when we were
primitive man and so as we're taking
these things we're trying to figure out
new ways to hunt new ways to protect
ourselves from our enemies new ways to
farm we start inventing things and start
inventing language to think there's a
direct connection between psilocybin use
and the ability to create words and
language so really we are what we are
just nature yeah we just keep evolving
and evolving
we're nature that lives in houses yeah
that's what we are that's crazy right
now that I'm thinking like so the
shrooms so really everything came from
this room and this room kind of trim
used us yeah this room used as in
growing in interesti the shroom used us
to manifest reality the the shroom used
us to create life it's not just a shroom
it's the ideas too like I think all
these ideas that you get we were talking
about this earlier like what is an idea
if you have an idea like hey I'm gonna
invent this thing this thing's gonna
benefit mankind you just have some crazy
idea that's supposed to fix things maybe
it sucks pollution out of the air and
then someone takes that and runs with it
and improve something else then someone
takes that and improves something that
you're doing this
among on giant scales millions and
millions and millions of people are
doing this and they're contributing to
this and they're all using ideas they
have ideas then they turn that idea into
a physical form and then every year they
expect it to get better and better and
better every year they innovate nobody
ever looks at a television he goes 72
inches it looks clear let's just stop no
more TVs it's blue guy they give always
gotta get bigger always but why is that
the reward is improvement like it's
constantly gearing towards improvements
like that
it's boredom boredom boredom makes us do
more and these are ideas or
ideas that we turn into things and along
the way there's a bunch of [ __ ] that
fuels our desire to get those things and
make these things happen like lust like
materialism like maybe what materialism
or people worry about it being so empty
maybe what it is it's a function of
getting us to invest heavily in newer
better [ __ ] so that more things
accelerate faster and faster and that
these new inventions come in a faster
and faster rate because that's what
we're constantly focused on his newer
better [ __ ] so they're constantly
inventing and improving and all the
while we're just dumping money into the
birth of our successor yeah the the
technology so we're just a movement we
evolved from the shrooms to the human to
the ideas to the culture to the
different cultures interacting with each
other the resistance of these cultures
interacting with each other so whether
we just organism we're an organism yeah
a [ __ ] awesome one though having as
much of a [ __ ] [ __ ] they talking about
ain't nobody getting shot anybody doing
all that type of [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
boring to me nobody sent a cameo through
the air they face time in Viking porn
you know nobody's flying helicopters
ain't that submarines pianets submarines
man yeah and you've never seen no
goddamn ain't never seen no lying 120
feet yeah I done that
[Applause]